we're really in u.s. championship mode
these days especially here at the club I
mean I don't know if you guys have
visited Lester's next door inside all
the chaos there and then downstairs
they're going to building this beautiful
set so it will be a permanent home for
broadcasting of major events right now
the ceilings missing and it's all got to
be ready by you know the first round
which starts April Fool's Day which may
be unintentional it's April Fool's Day
so we're in u.s. championship mode and
there was one game that was played in
the u.s. championship I think it was
2012 between gotta camp ski and Hikaru
Nakamura and that round it was the 10th
round gotta camp ski by the way is one
like five of the last six US
Championships when you stop and think
about it you go damn I mean st. Louis
has been a second home to the man he
ought to get keys to the city you know
at this point and he's coming back this
year in April for you know his sixth the
US Championship and he's got to be
stopped by Hikaru Wesley so as the two
highest rated players at this moment in
this year in the US championship of 2012
God is on cruise control he's really
been doing great undefeated when a lot
of games Hikaru's been barely managing
to keep pace with him and this round I
believe it was the penultimate round
essentially and basically Hikaru had to
win with black otherwise gada was
cruising to victory here we go that's
the setup
efore already an indication
that God is in more than just a simple
league combative moody he's not playing
d4 which he could easily have played and
tried to get a slow but secure type of
advantage he's trying to mix it up right
from the get-go
efore and when you got a win with black
well as sharp Sicilian can be your best
weapon remember that there was a game
tal was in a Soviet championship where
tall as black was in a must-win
situation and tall chose the caro-kann
well the journalists were shocked and
tal won the game and the journalist said
well you know like how could you make
the choice of the caro-kann which has a
drawing reputation in a must-win game he
says well when I play for the win I play
with her Caro when I played the dribbler
draw I played this Sicilian yeah okay
efore c5 Knight f3 d6 and we have our
pardon me we have our Knight orff and as
we know in the night or you can go for
the men's complications you might get
from Bishop g5 or you might play it the
let us say the English attack with
Bishop g4 follow Bishop e3 followed by
f3 followed by g4 Queen d2 what all the
British grandmasters from John Donne
Micky Adams Nigel short have done hence
the term English attack gotta went for a
positional approach a2 a4 basically
saying hey I'm just here to stop you
from playing B 7 B 5 what are you gonna
do the karo said okay well I'll play a
bola Slav ski system with E 5 and
there's no Bishop b5 check let me just
point that out one more time that in
this position ie 5 is actually
really really fine move this is a great
move if it wasn't for one small detail
in the position you might think that
well the move e5 has weakened the square
f5 and you're inviting the Knight to f5
well that's not actually true after for
example Knight f5 Knight takes e4 Knight
takes g7 Czech Bishop takes g7 Knight
takes e4 black could get a very nice
game after d5 the problem with E 5 in
this position is as I've just pointed
out the square f5 is very weak and it's
because of this reason Bishop b5 check
now the problem is black doesn't want to
trade light squared Bishop Spees made a
outpost for white on the d5 square
you can't play knight c6 because you'll
just lose in exchange Knight d7 Knight
f5 very nice position for white the
knight is excellent on f5 the pawn on d6
is weak and black is strongly advised
please don't play this variation for
black hence the move a 7 a 6 a 4 now
comes a 5 now there's no Bishop b5 check
there's no Knight f5 white has played
there's been tons and tons of games with
Knight f3 92 as well as Knight b3 gotta
chose Knight f3 in a certain sense in
the Sicilians there are certain
victories that vote both players might
have I'm not a big fan of this retreat
Knight f3 the reason is once the night
is on f3 and it impedes the pawn on f2
there's no F to f4 there's no G to g4
type of Sicilian attacks that you may
encounter for example in the English
attack or the Yugoslavia TAC and the
dragon so the knight on f3 is not I
just in the same way that sometimes the
knight on c3 is an ideal sometimes you
want the pawn on c4 like in an amor up
see so in this particular situation
setup I don't like this knight on f3 I
prefer the other retreats Knight B 392
that was goddess choice Bishop came to
e7 all of these moves by the way
whatever acquittals of criticisms I may
have is all pretty standard theory so
far it's all theory Bishop to e6 as we
understand there's this outpost on d5 so
in a sense both players are fighting for
control over the d5 square white is
reluctant to make the capture for the
simple reason that the pawn on e6 is
actually very useful it protects the
squares f5 and d5 oops excuse me and at
the same time the pawn on e5 blacks
massive pawns if you will are doing
pretty good work in controlling keep
crucial central squares so we had the
Bishop b3 knight c6 Bishop g5 again this
fight for the for control of the d5
square if you give black if if black
gives white the move for example h6
would be a terrible decision Bishop
takes Bishop takes Knight d5 and white
has all he could hope to achieve he's
put his night on the d5 square this play
by black along the C file can be stopped
simply with c2 c3 there's no play on the
Queen side black is stuck this is not a
good position for black
but black has a very good move which he
karo played for me let me just see what
I've got
yes again rook c8 would also have been a
bad move rook c8 Bishop takes Bishop
takes again the ideal for White has been
achieved but Knight a5 was simply
excellent the idea again it's a fight
for the d5 square if you can play Knight
takes b3 black will have more than
equalized he'll have gone from an equal
position to equal plus position in this
favor Bishop takes Bishop takes Bishop
d5 so the key difference and it may look
like a detail but it's a very important
one White has been forced to occupy the
square d5 not with a knight on c3 with
the bishop on d5 that's not a very
effective outpost for the bishop because
it turns out after the move rook c8 that
White's experiencing unpleasant pressure
down the C file in a previous variation
when the knight was on d5 we could
neutralize the C file with the move c2
c3 that is not available for white
White's kind of stuck for a plan if we
look at the position from White's point
of view when we see this knight on f3 we
say it's not on a particularly great
circuit can't go to d4 e v g5 h for all
the squares are covered on a very good
day we can imagine that blacks intent is
as simple as maybe putting his knight on
c4 putting his Queen on b6
putting pressure against this pawn on b2
and what's white doing for a long-term
plan so Knight d2 so for me this was
kind of indication number one that
something had gone a little bit wrong
for white that black already had
achieved a great deal and perhaps did
better
Queen c7 rook e1 Bishop e5 this was all
more almost really a kind of a bell
ringing moment when in fact it became
very clear that what that black and
indeed didn't stand better that this
Bishop is simply just awesome on the g5
square also if we notice this Queen on
c7 this rook on c8 gunning down for this
pawn on T on see to whites knight on c3
is also kind of stuck Knight f1 Queen b6
rook be one night c4 and we all really
realizing that a carro needing to win is
really getting a very nice position
Queen e2 Bishop h6 okay
tactics we all fall victim to tactics
time and time and time and time again
I'm speaking out of personal experience
one of the really let us say
overwhelming tactics are simply double
attacks
that's what tactics really are you can
talk about a night for but what's a
night for double attack what's a pawn
for a double attack a lot of tactics are
simply double attacks and you fall
victim to tactics because your pieces
aren't protected so I really like this
move Bishop h6 it's kind of one of those
moves which it says my bishops hanging
on g5 so I'm going to protect my bishop
I'm not going to be fall I'm not going
to be victimized by a tactic I like this
move very much a good way to protect it
and also it kind of ask a question for
white well what are you gonna do next
it's your turn
gada came up with the move h4 again it
kind of is a fishy kind of smelling move
I wasn't really sure about this move but
at least I understood II had a plan from
godess point of view his knight on f1 on
me his knight on f1 isn't any great
shakes and maybe on a good day the
knight could end up on g4 and harass the
bishop on h6 keeping in mind that for
the moment there's a Bishop d2 in the
position that White has to also be aware
of Queen before you black should not
fall Vic should not get greedy and play
a move like Knight takes B to simply
Knight d1 and oops-a-daisy there's a pin
on the B file that's going to cost
capice so Queen before and again it just
seems like blacks in cruise mode
everything is going in blacks favor at
this moment and I didn't really
understand what white was doing nobody
likes it but a suggestion I might have
made is our meme is back here I think it
was here sir pardon me a suggestion I
might have made was Bishop takes e4 I
don't like giving up my LightSquared
bishop but at least I have a plan
my plan would be 93 and on a good day I
would plant my knight why do I keep
doing that I think I got some I would
plant my knight on d5 and I'm not happy
with white but at least I know what I'm
doing and the game I didn't think that
God has idea was that good Knight b6
very very nice move and whites in deep
deep trouble now in the first place
black simply wants to capture if black
can ever capture on d5 and force white
to recapture with the pawn this is a
good deal for black it means that the
backward pawn on d6 on a half-open file
is no longer vulnerable the pawn on e5
is excellent and by the way blacks rooks
on the C file are excellent in addition
there's an A for pawn under attack I
thought white was in trouble after this
mode I thought that white that God was
going to sacrifice upon God has moved
surprised me a great deal he played the
move Bishop b3 which actually sacrifices
his C to pawn at the time the game was
played I thought God
was going to play rook d1 in order that
after lots of trades on d5 to recapture
with the rook and after Knight takes a
four Queen takes a four simply play the
move c2 c3 he's a pawn down yes he's a
pawn down and I'm not happy about that
but at least I have some play in the
position for one thing this pawn on d6
is certainly vulnerable I have ideas of
Bishop takes and rook takes d6 while
you're not looking and also I'll find a
better circuit for this night on f1
maybe it'll go to h2 and g4 gotta played
a sacrifice that I had not anticipated
he sacrificed a C to pawn it's funny
exactly at this point I thought
everything was cruising that Hikaru was
doing great that he had outplayed gotta
from the opening that he had won upon
that he stood well and I vastly
underestimated White's position as well
see gada played a five-night a4 which is
a very understandable move black wants
to be able to play rook C - now that was
exactly here that I began to understand
a little bit for the first time that
things weren't as cut and dry as I had
led myself to believe I'll just take a
poll from this position how many of you
think blacks doing great and was winning
how many think White's not so bad not so
bad but given the choice of what which
side how many would prefer black exactly
that was my feeling as well
but while gada was contemplating his
move I began to have doubts for example
in the game got a play tonight h2 which
really came as a great surprise like
night h2 what on earth has that I think
everybody would have played 95 and I
think goddess should have played 95 and
had he played 95 I think this game would
have been wild as can be so of course
the rook on c7 is hanging and the most
natural move and perhaps the move that
God a feared would be rook c2 but then
God it has the move Queen d1 ok now if
black continues with Knight takes b2
winning a second pawn it looks
overwhelming until you see the move
Knight e7 check King h8 Queen takes d6
and then it's one of those whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa who's attacking who kind
of situations because things have spun
out of control White has a threat of
Knight g6 check and capturing this rook
on f8 and white could generate some
substantial threats from this position
also one has to ask is this Knight
really that great I mean you know
standing in front of the Queen like this
the tide could easily turn so at this
moment I thought he god I would play 95
instead he played the move Knight h2 and
oftentimes it's not easy for me to
understand the moves of you know really
world-class players
so rather than belligerently or
prejudicially say oops he blundered he
didn't play the move I wanted I'm
actually forced to kind of
you know show a little respect just a
smidge for the players at the board and
say okay why did he do that then you
start looking a little bit and you say
to yourself oh my goodness if white is
able to play the move Knight g4 that
Bishop on h6 stuck and furthermore if I
could then play the move Knight takes h6
check doubling up the pawns on the Kings
side it might easily happen that black
is victimized by a perpetual check or
maybe worse maybe the King get sacked so
now I started to really warm up to God
his idea of Knight h2 when he karo
played the move g6
very understandably he gives his Bishop
a secure home Bishop g7 now comes the
move Knight d5 Queen rook c2 a moment
ago I was talking about Queen d1 now God
have played the move Queen e3 and I
understood the whole idea of chasing
that bishop from age six away so that
the Queen could come to e3
if black trades Queens pardon me excuse
me
if black in this position trades Queens
takes Knight takes rook takes rook takes
Knight takes rook here Knight here
rook takes this is a more or less a
dream position for white all of his
pieces are good he's got this knight on
d5 he's got this rook on b7
after for example Knight c5 rook here
sure black has a pawn but in this exact
position the a pawns the most dangerous
pawn on the board and it will be
involved in whites at favor disposition
so we go back and here I really
appreciate it
Knight c5 and the position of God
and the more I looked at this position I
began to wonder wait a minute who's
better here like who's better it was
from this point unfortunately for gotta
that almost on every single move it was
like he was playing second best choices
or missing his real opportunities
because in a weird way White has a
really nice maneuver here that gada has
missed in the game in the game got a
plate h5 not a bad move but he could
have played oops excuse me he could have
played check instantly ok two choices
for black if black plays King h8 Knight
d7 where did that come from Knight d7
I'm attacking the rook on f8 I'm
attacking the knight on c5 rook c8
Knight takes e5 I'm attacking the Queen
on b3 if in this position Queen takes
III I'll play Knight takes III in the
immortal words of Nikolai man have gift
me Europe so we go back look c8 Knight
takes e5 Queen takes III Knight takes
rook takes b4 let's put the rook on a
good square for a moment rook c3 Knight
d5 and again White has achieved as ideal
he's got this dominating night
he's down upon but that pawn is a block
pawn them on b6 against a bad bishop and
maybe it's easier to play white in this
position after white plays b5 and opens
up the B file so from this position
Knight f6 check I thought was very
strong just a second and in case of
Bishop takes f6 Knight takes f6 King g7
of course we don't want to allow
ourselves to be checkmated no hate that
King g7 night h5 check there's a draw on
the spot right there with Knight h5
check at least for white takes check
check check
and so forth White's not worse at all
but gotta perhaps he did see this move
Knight d7 but already he was optimistic
of his winning chances and he played the
move h5 and maybe he wasn't wrong Queen
takes III Knight takes III rook d2
Knight c4 rook d4 Knight takes D 6 all
of these moves were very forcing rupp d
8 b 4 night here Knight takes Knight
takes rook takes very very forced
sequence and black is happy blacks in
exchange up how cool is that and at the
time that this game was played because
it went rather quickly to this position
I thought somebody had made an error in
judgment and like all good journalists
I'm prejudiced by the result
black won the game white made the error
in judgment I have right had won the
game it's very easy as a journalist
black made the error in judgment so
because black won the game I was
impressed by the result and therefore I
thought you know
gotta had aired the more I looked at
this game thereafter and as well as
preparing for this lecture I think white
is doing fine
absolutely fine we can see at the moment
that this rook on d8 is under attack but
very shortly after this move rook moves
this night is going to come to C 5 is
going to take this pawn on a6 and then
after b5 b6 black and resign it's that
simple
black does not want to lose his a6 pawn
and hence played the move rook e8 and
now come some funny
funky mistakes question to the audience
what would you play if you had white
Juliet me too yeah anybody else want to
play anything different than 95 get that
night back into the game
put that night sweetly on c5 F 2 F 3 bi
gotta never saw that move calling Julian
yes
rook c1 to play the pardon me
rook c1 to play rook c7 is why God a
played f3 he wanted to protect his pawn
on e4 but the funny part is he doesn't
need his rook on the seventh rank let's
think about this another way for a
moment let's say he had played Julian's
move in my move as well Knight c5 first
of all this protects the pawn on e4
so that releases our rook that means
that we can move our rook anywhere we
want to and let's imagine it we had a
very good sunny day and black allowed us
to do something so let's say that black
played the move rook a7
we played rook a1 black played rook a8
we took upon
and it was suddenly dented it signed my
score sheet resign whoa
suddenly we understand there's a very
serious threat in the position for white
so let's go back here rook a8 Knight c5
is our main move let's say Bishop f8 in
order to attack the honey rook h1 ooh
how's that for move rook h1 so if it's
white turn to play what white would like
to do is like white would like to go
Knight to d7 knight on d5 to f6 check
take the pawn on g6 in mate with the
rook so white setting up a mating
pattern if black defends along the
seventh through the rookie 7 we have
takes takes check and at least a
perpetual Julian
instead of rook h1 I like rock h1 no you
can't play rook h1 will come back
rook a rookie 7 hg hg Knight f6 this is
the draw pardon me and there was another
line I wanted to look at for exam
Roque 895 rook a7 rook a1 bishop f8
Knight takes a 6 and I wanted to show
you just this position for a moment
because I thought it was a very funny
position is a positional draw there's
like rights a rook down but the two
pawns are holding the bishop on a7 and
the rook on b8 at bay and I just like
this position very much it makes what
the British would call a visual
impression or simply very visual nice
let's go back to what Julian wanted to
ask Julian wanted to ask can he play
Knight a7 I forbid him to ask this
question I think I will bail out I'll
take this man you can take my rook if
you like that now I've got a tempo and
the initiative has shifted its black
who's in the driver's seat yeah okay so
I think that after Knight c5 I could
show a number of variations where gada
would wonder won the US Championship I
was about to say the World Championship
close enough right ah similar US
Champion world champion
got a head he played the most obvious
move on the board 95 would likely have
at least drawn the game
and won the US Championship he did not
do that he played f2 f3 perhaps again he
was influenced by the idea that he
really had a lot of compensation and
maybe he over he he thought too much of
his position
Bishop f8 now rook c1 which was Bishop
takes b4 rook c7 I think it was here
that God got a missed his maybe not his
very last chance but certainly one of
his last chances after this capture
Bishop takes b4 there was really one way
that white could have made black's life
very difficult and for those of you who
are very familiar with Czech mating
patterns you would recognize you really
want to play h6 you'd really want to
play h6 here as white on a very good day
you get to go rook c7 Knight f6 check
and who knows maybe the promised land of
checkmate after h6 Bishop would have
dropped back rook would have gone to c7
Bishop would take the pond Knight would
play Knight d6 threatening the pawn on
f7 rook would have to go to f8 then rook
to a7 and after rook takes a6 these
Knights are really you know in the
position let's continue the line that I
had looked at f5 takes check here takes
Knight check Knight takes and even
though black isn't exchanged up thanks
to the incredibly reduced material 2 and
1 on the Kings side very active pieces
for white remember they're still an a
pond on the board as well
White's chances for a draw should not
the underestimated here I think that
this is more it's not bad it's still
good for black I prefer black of course
but it was a good chance after what was
played in the game however was this G
takes h5 I think got a missed how
important this was now blacks King is
relatively safe there's no more
you know harassing checks and things of
that nature
pawn isn't on h6 and blacks King has
King g7 King g6 when needed here this is
time trouble king h2 h3 and this was a
really great move by Hikaru sorry I
didn't get it right here
rook a 7 pinning this night on b7 and
after this I think it's game over whites
opportunities just have all gone the
game continued King takes h5 rook takes
d5 Bishop takes a 5 oops
houston we have a problem the rook on c7
is hanging it's in a pin and rookie 7
Bishop d6 d6 a5 and away the pawn goes
White has no moves if white plays in
this position night d8 pardon me D yet
d7 King 6 wins and if he plays Knight d8
King f8 wins the D pawn is going nowhere
which moment this now right now
d6 ooh sorry
d6 why not d6 I suspect he takes takes
rook night let's just see our can the
knight get back in time ooh that wasn't
good over right Knight takes push how do
we get back hmm do we get back I don't
think we get back did I do it wrong
maybe I can use the check new variation
here check here here here here here I
got a feeling that this is going to win
for black because blacks king is making
a beeline for the white knight thank you
for the question though because it's
totally legit
what about d6 it just it just happened
as we saw that
it's close but no cigar
okay so let's see where are we okay so
we were back here takes takes takes rook
e7 Bishop b6 d6 a5 King g5 was played in
the game but it's already too late the a
pawn is just going up the board here I
thought that he Caro played it well he
could have played King f8 I think that
would have forced resignation on the
spot he played a to check and gotta
threw in the towel and thanks to this
result the US Champion in 2012 was
Hikaru Nakamura but that was a very very
interesting matchup of styles where it
looked that from the opening and from
the early middle game period black
really had a lot going white didn't have
much but once white got his knight on d5
the compensation really blossomed and
there were a lot of favorable tactics
and just on a better day in better form
this could easily have been God as US
Championship as well
you